lewis lapham is editor of Harper's
Magazine he's compiled his response to
the events of sep tember 11th in the new
book theater of war next mr. Lapham
joins a panel of journalists at the
independent Institute for a discussion
on the war on terrorism it's an hour and
45 minutes
James Madison the master builder of the
US Constitution noted that quote if
tyranny and oppression come to this land
it will be in the guise of fighting a
foreign enemy unquote indeed President
Bush now calls for a new foreign policy
of a limited unilateral and first-strike
intervention against all countries that
might someday threaten us supremacy
while those responsible for a 911 remain
at large we now face the prospects of a
war in Iraq and elsewhere combined
domestically with the Orwellian USA
PATRIOT Act tips domestic spying program
Department of Homeland Security
incarceration without charge or trial
militarized law enforcement and airport
security national ID cards and growing
port protectionism and corporate welfare
our speaker this evening has long been
an insightful critic of human falling
especially that of war and the interest
groups through feed off it this evening
we seek to facilitate a better
discussion of the US war on terrorism
for light to welcome all of our
participants and if you'd please hold
your applause until I make complete the
introductions a San Francisco native
lewis lapham became editor of Harper's
Magazine in 1971 having worked for the
San Francisco Examiner and the New York
Herald Tribune their author of many
books he received the 1995 national
magazine award award for his Harper's
call a notebook mr. Lapham has been the
host of two PBS series and for those who
had not seen this new book is called
theater of war and here's a copy as soon
as he mentioned our panel of journalists
includes Alan back of the Orange County
Register also a columnist for
antiwar.com is the author of the books
waiting to inhale the politics of
medical marijuana the ecology action
guide and ambush at Ruby Ridge
next to him Jonathan Marshall is former
economics editor for the San Francisco
Chronicle the recipient of many awards
in journalism is the author of numerous
books on Foreign Affairs including the
books drug wars the iran-contra
connection and cocaine politics next to
him Seth rosin fell from the San
Francisco Chronicle won a landmark
17-year legal battle under the Freedom
of Information Act forcing the FBI to
release two hundred thousand pages of
documents about as covert activities at
the University of California to disrupt
the free speech movement and other
activities finally Paul Weaver has been
an editor with Fortune magazine and the
Public Interest a professor at Harvard
University and a public affairs officer
at Ford Motor Company Amongus books are
news and the culture of line and the
suicidal corporation please join me in
welcoming our participants
a couple of quick program format matters
before we begin after the discussion
we'll have questions from the audience
on the card in your printed program
please simply jot down your question
during the presentations and there will
be Usher's circulating the aisles to
pick them up after the question period
we will adjourn also and mr. Lapham will
be available to autograph his book in
front outer lobby now I'm most pleased
to present lewis lapham
well I am honored and greatly to be here
as you know I'm from San Francisco and
it gives me great joy to come back to
the city and to talk to so many people
out the so I'm I thank you for for
coming the I've written over the last
year quite a lot about our ongoing war
against terrorism and I'm hard to know
where to start the it is of course a war
against an unknown enemy and an abstract
noun and we do know that shortly after
nine eleven 2001 mr. Rumsfeld explained
that it was a war that could last for 30
or 40 years or maybe forever it's Lee
it's like a war against well it is it's
the war against all the world's evil
doers it's like trying to it's like the
war on drugs or the war on poverty or
the war on lust or the war on pride
it never ends and it from the point of
view of Washington I think well I think
one of the things that I that we've
learned in the last year or so has been
the distance between the military and
foreign policy establishment in
Washington and what we can now call the
American street in other words the I
don't find despite what the polls say I
never trust the polls anyway but I don't
find broad eager sentiment for the war
on terrorism or for the forthcoming
invasion of Iraq the magazine has
descended over the last 12 months in our
newsstand sale has been going steadily
up not a lot of this opinion seems to
show up in the in the mainstream media
and I begin to think that from the point
of view of the military foreign policy
establishment in Washington the attack
on the World Trade Towers and the
Pentagon can be seen as a blessing in
disguise no cloud without a silver
lining because consider what has
happened the attack rescued the
presidency of george w bush in august of
2001 the economy was beginning to fall
into decline the republicans had lost
control of the senate the only
accomplishment that Bush had
had to his credit was the tax cut that
benefited a very small and wealthy
percentage of the population the
conservative compassion of the to come
campaign of two thousand was not was
looking not very compassionate and
suddenly and it was possible to confuse
bush with with an ornament of the
American corporate loot aqua sees along
the lines of a prize fish on a country
club wall within within a matter of days
after the attack he has suddenly
pronounced the pier of Lincoln and
Churchill these are the remarks of the
washington post and the colonists in the
new york times it also within another
within another six weeks we have the
passage of the USA PATRIOT Act put
forward by Ashcroft who is our attorney
general and who believes and who has
said that in the United States we have
no king but Jesus and He as you know he
begins his meetings every morning into
Justice Department with people standing
around in a circle of Prayer holding
hands and singing songs of the Attorney
General's own composition these songs
are available on the internet you can
you can actually I promise you they are
frightening to listen to but the so we
we have the patriot act and I'm sure
most of you in this room understand the
seizure of police powers on the part of
the government that essentially the
government can now open anybody's mail
tap anybody's phone search anybody's
proud premises without a warrant the and
we've had to we organizations that that
bill by the way passed through both
houses of Congress with very few hours
of debate and we've also had two
reorganizations of the FBI in the last
12 months in each reorganization
improving upon the authoritarian
prerogatives implicit in the Patriot Act
the other blessing of course has been
for the the military budget the we now
have with terrorism and terrorists and
Hussein had an enemy to take the place
of the old Soviet Union for many years
in my entire memory the country has been
at war
I can remember as a child in San
Francisco World War two I can remember
the ships in the bay and I can then
remember this the very quick segue into
the Cold War into the national security
state into heavier and heavier emphasis
on secrecy and on security more and more
money being spent our greatest or
treasurer on our Arsenal on me i can
even i could say that the that our
greatest artworks or our armaments are
missiles they are the equivalent of the
short cathedral or the Sistine ceiling
we live we lavish enormous intelligence
imagination money on these demonic
weapons we also have had I also as I'm
sure everybody in this room also has
lived under the the fear threat of
nuclear annihilation for the last 50 odd
years the I remember internalizing that
fear during the Cuban Missile Crisis of
1962 when the missiles were supposedly
own roots from from Cuba but again the
the whole notion of the country at war
the notion that war is the health of the
state a phrase coined by Randolph burn
born in the early part of the century is
true and yet the now that we have the
war on terrorism and the notion that we
can the doctrine of pre-emptive action
forward deterrence committing us to god
knows what kind of military response and
at any point in the world is is now you
could have said that the Soviet Union
was as necessary to the American economy
as General Motors or Iowa corn and it
begins to look as if we can say the same
thing about the war on terrorism but of
course we have to sell it as a we can't
say that quite we can't say that in that
it is such a naked commercial or
political or hegemonic purpose so we
have to present it as a crusade and
President Bush has been doing that for a
year drawing the line in the sand
between good and evil an axis of evil
discovered in the State of the Union
address last January and his language is
is religious he sounds almost as if he
is a medieval Pope summoning
the faithful to it too again never
ending war with the infidel and this is
backed up in the language of of Ashcroft
and on the language of quite a few of
the people who are close to two rumsfeld
and cheney in the Defense Department and
what strikes me is the is the lack of
dissent we don't seem to have very many
voices in Congress arguing against the
juggernaut or trying to find what the
real reasons are for our forthcoming
invasion of Iraq I listened to President
Bush's speech at the UN on September
12th and although I could see that it
was persuasive to some of our European
allies and possibly to some of our more
friendly Muslim states in the Middle
East certainly it seemed it appealed to
the editorial writers in the times and
the post but I I found nothing in the
speech convincing or making the case for
making the argument for war and then I
remembered Donald Rumsfeld at a press
conference NATO press conference last
June in Brussels and he was being asked
by some of the European reporters to
come up with reasons or proofs or how
are we doing with the war on terrorism
and so on and he assured them
there were many reasons close at hand
top secret not to be trusted to your
journalist and anyone on to say that you
have to remember that the absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence
under under those rules the war can last
forever and we all can be said to jail
there there so and I honestly don't
understand why more of the Democrats in
Congress aren't arguing the point or
making fun of ridiculing some of the
positions of the administration I am
distressed by the contempt with which
Rumsfeld and Cheney addressed not only
the American media but the the American
people I'm surprised that that doesn't
make that there's an arouse more anger
the the another example two weeks ago I
think it was two weeks ago at Camp David
Bush was was there with Blair Tony Blair
them Britain and he held up a photograph
of what purported to be a online nuclear
weapons facility in Iraq
and then went on to quote a report by
the International Atomic Energy
Commission saying that this photograph
represented a working facility and was
close to or capable of making a nuclear
bomb on this was offered in in evidence
and within two hours of that
demonstration on television the
International Atomic Energy Commission
pointed out that a the photograph was
four years old to that the what was
attributed to the report of by the
International Atomic Energy Commission
was a complete distortion the Commission
had never said that there was no way
that Hussein possessed the means or the
capability to make a weapon and they
only wrecked the only report of that
contradiction on the part of the
International Atomic Energy Commission
that I saw was in in the Financial Times
a British newspaper I never saw in any
of the American papers that may have
been there but I didn't see it in the in
The Times or in the Washington Post so
it's similar to what happened in
nineteen ninety nineteen ninety during
the build-up to the first war against
Adam Hussein when a satellite photograph
was too
I go back the part of the pretext for
the war was the massing of Iraqi tanks
on the border of Saudi Arabia soon to be
unleashed against the oil fields and
against Riyadh and this was one of the
reasons for our intervention the
photograph which was acquired through an
independent source satellite imaging
French satellite imaging company was
acquired by the st. Petersburg Times and
the photograph showed there were no
tanks that photograph appeared only in
the st. Petersburg Times it was not it
was offered to the network's it was
offered to the major newspapers but they
because it was not a government handout
because it had not been given to them by
the Pentagon they didn't print it and we
now of course we have a media that is
largely is the entertainment business
and the Pentagon learned one lesson in
in Vietnam which was not to let the
cameras or the reporters get too close
to the news they could get within five
miles posed on the roof tasteful
wardrobe desert tan burning buildings in
the background but that was it and so
our news correspondents the ABC
newspaper in this news correspondents
cannot get very close to the whatever is
going on in Afghanistan however ABC is
owned by Disney and Disney hired Jerry
Bruckheimer who's a movie producer who
produced Top Gun and black hawk down to
make an 18 part series
all the war in Afghanistan and to make
it with the assistance of the Pentagon
and to presented as an eight and that
will be presented as news on ABC
television so his sense is is essential
of democracy depends on candor it
depends on people saying what they think
what they know counting on their fellow
citizens to respond and kind that we
tell each and we try to tell each other
the truth that's what makes democracy
work and I'm afraid that that what we're
seeing here toward the beginning of the
21st century is the decay of the
Democratic Republic and the rise of I
don't know what the people in Washington
like to refer refer to it as the new
American Empire and you you read
commentary like that in the
neoconservative press part of the
mainstream journals I had a wonderful
quote yeah here the chart this is
charles krauthammer in Time magazine and
an instant remark that could be taken as
representative of the attitudes in place
and I think in a representative the
attitudes packing the endless war on
terrorism and here is here is the line
America is no mere international citizen
it is the dominant power in the world
more dominant than any since Rome
accordingly America is in a position to
reshape norms alter expectations and
create new realities how by unapologetic
and implacable
demonstrations of will now that to me
it's straightforward folly hubris
carried to a point which is tragic
because we do not have that kind of
power and when I'm thinking about
descent I think of a pain I mean descent
has always been hard in this country
it's never it never draws a cheering
crowd it's not popular 20 pain was as
you know rights the founding document of
the American Revolution common sense
which shortly after the Revolutionary
War he he goes to England and then he
goes to France takes part in the French
Revolution in England he writes a book
called Rights of Man which and the
British aristocracy declare him and
outlaw and he has to flee for his life
and then he goes to to Paris becomes a
member of the French assembly and he
argues after Louis the sixteenth is in
prison and the revolution the rose
pierre are arguing the point as to
whether or not to execute him guillotine
the king and the Queen and pain stands
up and argues against that he says look
you had a revolution it the argument is
not with the person with of the king the
argument is with monarchy why don't you
be the first nation in the world to
declare null and void the death penalty
for that remark he is himself thrown
into the luxembourg prison and placed
under the sentence of death by the
guillotine and mrs. it only by accident
by a few days I mean he is scheduled to
die on a certain day in August and the
day before he is scheduled to die the
revolution turns against rose pierre and
robes Pierre his himself which saves
pain but when he comes back to the
United States he's reviled because as a
blasphemer because he has written a book
calling into question the authority of
the Christian religion and the United
States is a very religious country was
then is now which is one of the reasons
that Bush has to sell the war be endless
war against terrorism as a religious
crusade and John Adams describes pain as
the insolent blasphemer of all things
sacred and transcendent Bible ER of all
that is good and pain is not allowed to
be buried in the United States in
hallowed ground he's buried in a
equivalent of a ditch in some property
New Rochelle and throughout the 19th
century he was preachers all over the
country would refer to him as old Tom
which was a synonym for the devil and
when some people wanted there came a
moment when some of pains admirers
wanted maybe place his head on Mount
Rushmore and Teddy Roosevelt who was the
head of the Commission as to whose head
went on on Rushmore
dismissed pain as a dirty little atheist
the pain would have recognized the
government now in Washington I think as
as what he was protesting against in
common sense a government Federalist in
its mistrust of freedom the mean them
the passion for secrecy and on the part
of the administration and it's mistrust
of freedom its mistrust of individuals
which is also evidenced in the USA
patriot act to me is awful to behold
imperialist in its bluster evangelical
in its worship of property when White
House we have a president appointed by
the Supreme Court in the Justice
Department an attorney general it
believes that God wrote the Constitution
and in Congress a corpulent majority
than on matters of tax and regulatory
policy boats its allegiance to the
principles of hereditary succession and
class privilege I'm just getting started
so but the
that's the right time
why but what last point of the point is
that that dissent is always a is always
hard Tocqueville knew that tween knew
that there's a wonderful debate in 1900
in Madison Square Garden between Twain
who is the head of the Eddie
imperialists League a man in his 70s he
wrote against the spanish-american i'm
outside well yes against the
spanish-american war and then against
the American occupation of the
Philippines and couldn't get those
writings published during his lifetime
because the editors thought they were
unsuitable in a time of high and
patriotic feeling and he has it this
debate that is going on I wish was going
on more vividly now than it is but 1900
between is arguing what I take to be the
Democratic position not for war not for
the American Empire and on the other
side the best-selling writer of the day
best-selling writer in American 1900 is
Winston Churchill was 23 years old and
as a debate between these two men one of
them in his 70s the other in his 20s and
it's the same argument that we're now
having and it's it's the same argument
that we're that we had during the
Vietnam War and
I just I just wish there was more of the
argument thank you
Thank You Louis will have a chance to
speak with Louis more during the Q&A
period I'd like to start with our
panelist our first panelist is Alan bak
thank you David Thank You Luis and thank
all of you my goodness what a wonderful
turnout bring you greetings from
Southern California where where I grew
up and where I still manage to live and
I used to hate San Francisco just but
before I ever came in contact with it
it's one of the you know it's one of
those north-south kind of things but
having actually come and visited a
number of times over the years this is
such a such a wonderful place and again
we're seeing the specialness of San
Francisco I think tonight a good bit of
the discussion of what role if any US
foreign policy played in the terrorist
attacks last september's has been
bullied out of the marketplace by the
contention that any criticism of foreign
policy especially in the wake of 9-11
amounts to being an apologist for
terrorism or a knee-jerk blame America
first type with a country under attack
now is no time to be rehearsing yet
again the mistakes of the past or
undermining our resolve by carping at
the commander in chief don't you know
there's a war on the admonition not to
carp is not consistently applied however
I've heard a number of commentators been
given media time to lament the weakness
into your resolution of the Clinton
years when the commander-in-chief
distracted by Monica impeachment and
everything else fired missiles randomly
and insufficiently passed up several
chances to nab Osama bin Laden on a
silver platter if only our foreign
policy had been more resolute than maybe
September 11th might never have happened
so apparently it is fair game to
criticize u.s. foreign policy in harp
the past fine but let's have criticism
and backbiting from as many angles as
possible and I think we've had not
enough from his men enough different
angles let's get that game going in
suggesting as I will that US foreign
policy and it's intrusive and
interventionist character was
contributing factor to the terror
attacks is not an apology for terrorism
even if al Qaeda's cause whereas just
and pure as a Woodrow Wilson's nothing
could justify that kind of deliberate
attack on innocents who had nothing to
do with creating your real or imagined
grievances but if we really want to
reduce our vulnerability to terrorism
surely it can't be out of bounds to try
to understand the rage madness twisted
ideas or whatever it is that motivates
these terrorists if we discover as we
will that US foreign policy contributed
to that rage we might decide not to
change it life's full of trade-offs you
might just decide that you know an
attack on the world trade center every
so often is this is a reasonable price
to pay for being acknowledged as the
sole superpower and the bringer of truth
and enlightenment to the dark places of
the earth where democracy has not yet
triumphed but at least we should discuss
those risks and benefits openly and
acknowledge that there are both risks
and benefits to our policies I don't
know whether 911 can be classified
strictly as blowback the apparently CIA
originated term that chalmers johnson
professor emeritus at university of
california used to title his latest book
and incidentally i went down and had
lunch with him it is placed down north
of san diego what a delightful man
but you know blowback is you know sort
of the unexpected uninvited negative
aspects of an operation and every
operation has them even the best planned
and most successful have have have
negative aspects to them and sometimes
they blow up or right in your face but
there is at least evidence that it
motivated Osama bin Laden in statements
prior to 911 he specifically listed
listed the presence of US troops and
bases in the land containing Mecca and
other holy Islamic places is one of his
grievances now whether it was a real
motivator or a pretext I don't think you
could probably know without extensive
psychological analysis but it's got to
be significant that he mentioned it so
it ought to be worthy of some kind of
discussion we know and have known that
US policy toward Israel which I'm not as
critical of as some people i think it's
sort of support with kvetching but we
know that it angers a lot of Muslims the
US has troops in more than 130 countries
and interest everywhere it may be unfair
that others resent us and it is
undoubtedly true that resentment is
stirred up and manipulated by ambitious
and unscrupulous opportunists but fair
or not those resentments are there and
are not likely to disappear they're part
of the price of empire hegemony success
desire to share the benefits of your way
of life or whatever you want to call it
that to describe America's place in the
world any reflective material person
would should know this it turns out for
example as the Cato Institute pointed
out in a couple of policy studies
published prior to 911 which were in
turn based on Department of Defense
studies that the presence of heavy
concentrations of American positions
troops or activity in
part of the world is closely correlated
to increase terrorist activities now
that may not prove causality but it's
kind of interesting it's and it's hardly
a surprise the presence of a foreign
power even a perfectly benevolent one
will breed local resentment the Defense
Department knew this intuitively they
studied it to try to get a handle on it
if we acknowledge that a foreign policy
of intervention preemption or preventive
war and nation-building carries risks as
well as benefits will be in a better
position to develop intelligent policies
based on realistic information rather
than theories and dreams a few years ago
political science professor James Kurtz
halves worth more wrote a piece i think
it was in the national interest
characterizing empires using the
categories of the age and qualities of
the people they venerated and thus for
example he noted that the Roman Empire
tended to venerate the young bold
warrior may be in his late 20s or early
30s whereas the austro-hungarian Empire
venerated the guy with a white beard who
had lived a number of years and
accumulated experience and wisdom you
see all these portraits of these
austro-hungarians with a silver hair and
the great long beards and he said that
he then characterized America as the
adolescent Empire not just because we
haven't been at this Empire business
very long but because we're a culture
obsessed with youth and beauty we make
Britney Spears and NSYNC enormously
wealthy we want aging rock stars to
sound just like they did back in the day
unfortunately our attention span in
foreign affairs is about as long as that
if somebody who's already bored with
brittany and searching aimlessly for the
next big thing now that may not be a
terrible thing to say about Americans we
are kind of self-obsessed and we're
remarkably innocent but on the whole
kind of think of ourselves as benevolent
and well-intentioned and outside of a
narrow coterie of foreign policy
professionals and defense intellectuals
whatever that
might describe we don't have the
slightest interest in running an empire
or telling the rest of the world what to
do but to have their you know we want to
refinance your house or get a decorator
to get the next big job or follow our
own enthusiasms rather than worrying
about what some resentful loser on the
other side of the world wants to do to
you and yours because of what our
leaders have been doing in our name well
I think we'd maybe time for us to take
enough interest in foreign affairs to
derail that small band of would-be world
fixers who are running things now and
seem intent on getting us into more Wars
our next speaker a next panelist is
Jonathan Marshall
thank you very much so I was considering
what to say about the war on terrorism
that the title of tonight's discussion I
realized the whole topic is actually
pass a it has been since Bush gave his
State of the Union address early this
year and announced that the real issue
is the axis of evil and of course the
war on terrorism is now being relegated
to the footnotes except for our
occasional anniversary memorials the
real issue of course today is your rock
and soon to be Iran North Korea and
whatever other country gets on the list
of the axis of evil a couple of Bush's
admirers Robert Kagan and William
Kristol writing in the Weekly Standard a
leading conservative newspaper lauded
the administration for its expansive new
American foreign policy a paradigm shift
equal to the inauguration of
anti-communist containment they said
bush has taken the war on terrorism
beyond a police action and transformed
it into a campaign to uproot dangerous
Pyrenees and encourage democracy making
the world much safer for free peoples so
you can imagine where all of that will
lead to the the chosen instrument of
this new expansive policy that they are
lauding which goes far beyond the war on
terrorism is what is been so benignly
called regime change nicely antiseptic
term that we will soon be practicing on
Iraq and I wanted to spend just a few
minutes looking at the historical record
which unfortunately most of the media
have been want to do because regime
change is not a new aspect of American
foreign policy it's one that's been
going on Lewis mentioned the
intervention in the Philippines you can
go back even longer than that but it's
specifically looking at the Middle East
which is the focus of attention now I
thought it would be instructive to look
at a few examples of regime change our
current target Iraq has tasted this
medicine before twice in fact
with very interesting results the first
time was in 1963 when the CIA station in
Baghdad helped orchestrate the coup
against the reigning general and put in
a nuke group including members of the
Baath Party who had been biding their
time in Egypt and they succeeded with
CIA help in overthrowing the government
the CIA then handed over a list of
people who were later killed by the new
regime and one of the people that was
brought to power who was a young member
of the bath party with Saddam Hussein
brought to you by the CIA several years
passed of domestic turmoil and there was
a second queue in 1968 also brought
about with CIA help this time the Baath
Party was brought completely to power
and the deputy in charge of the new
regime was Saddam Hussein in 1979 he
took full charge as dictator of the
country and as you know within basically
two years he was the new darling of the
reagan-bush one administration having
invaded iran in 1980 taking on america's
new enemy the country that had of course
sees the American Embassy and was now
responding an islamic revolution
throughout the Middle East and as you
probably know the reagan-bush
administration gave the Iraqi regime
about a billion and a half dollars in
credits to buy high-tech equipment
including weapons gave them top-secret
satellite imaging to help them wage
their war against Iran and even gave
export licenses for the shipment of
nearly two dozen shipments of anthrax
along with botulin toxin and other nice
products that no doubt he put to good
use the reason that the Washington in
that time was in bed with Saddam Hussein
was we were trying to rectify the damage
that had been done
in Iran which as I mentioned as you all
know was the new American enemy the
damage done there was also a product of
regime change in 1953 when the
democratically elected government of
Moses egg had a couple of years earlier
nationalized the anglo-iranian oil
company and the British came to the
United States saying this was
unacceptable and jointly British
intelligence in the CIA wage operation
Ajax which was then long considered a
great success story for the CIA /
through most a day can put the Shah back
on the throne the Shahs you know
proceeded to throw kill thousands of
people throw tens of thousands into jail
spend and squander most of the country's
oil money on buying US and European arms
until finally an underground led by a
group of radical clerics among them the
Ayatollah Khomeini managed to win enough
popular support to overthrow the Shah in
1979 delivering this vast new problem on
to America's doorstep so that was regime
change number two or number three if you
count both Iraqi regime changes earlier
the Iranian Revolution spawned all of
the modern examples of militant
political Islam that we're seeing around
much of the world especially in the
Middle East and South Asia one of the
places that was infected by the bug was
Afghanistan in 1979 Afghanistan was
ruled by a secular regime which was
showing increasing pro-soviet tendencies
and among other policies that the regime
was conducting were policies of land
reform opium suppression and women's
rights along with their pro-soviet tilt
in foreign policy the Carter
Administration approved that's in the
summer of nineteen seventy-nine a
program of secret assistance to the
newly formed Mujahideen basically a
group of ultra conservative
rural groups some of them were Lords and
others who resented the central
government's modernizing tendencies and
as the State Department memo that summer
again 1979 said the United States is
larger interest would be served by the
demise of the regime despite whatever
setbacks this might mean for future
social and economic reforms in
Afghanistan the overthrow of the
government would show the rest of the
world particularly the third world that
the Soviets view of the socialist course
of history being inevitable is not
accurate so as a former national
security advisers vigna Brzezinski is
admitted CIA assistants started long
before the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan and indeed was designed in
part to provoke such an invasion
Brzezinski proudly told French
interviewers three or four years ago
that he was trying to provoke such an
invasion so that the Soviets would have
their own Vietnam and to this day he's
proud of that he thinks that was a great
victory well as we all know in trying to
create a Soviet Vietnam the United
States Armed trained and supplied the
new Mujahideen who were of course
Islamic fundamentalists many of them
subscribing to the most militant sex of
Islam promoted by extreme Saudi clerics
with Saudi support and support from
Pakistani military intelligence the CIA
supported a program of bringing in
Muslim revolutionaries from all over the
world to help with this revolt against
the government of Afghanistan to create
regime change ultimately as many as a
hundred thousand muslims from around the
world were brought into contact with
this with this effort and one of these
of course was Osama bin Laden who in
fact headed some of the key houses where
these Muslims were brought well today of
course we're paying the price in
Afghanistan were still bogged down with
no end in sight
trying to repair the country that we
help tear apart the two other countries
I've mentioned where we did regime
change are now two of the three members
of the axis of evil and Iraq is
preparing to take a third dose of regime
change medicine I think it's time we
wake up and recognize not only the
tremendous human cost in the region
itself of policies that we've been
conducted four years of regime change
but the tremendous cost of the United
States itself of such incredibly
short-sighted and counterproductive
policy thank
Thank You Jonathan our next speaker is
Seth Rosenfeld thank you very much I'm
very honored to be here tonight with
this panel before all of you to talk
about these issues attorney general john
ashcroft told the Senate Judiciary
Committee last December to those who
scare peace-loving people with phantoms
of lost Liberty my message is this your
tactics only aid terrorists for they
erode national unity and diminish our
resolve does that mean we're all under
arrest seriously the purpose tonight is
not to scare anybody the purpose tonight
is to discuss important issues and I
start from the premise that the FBI and
the CIA have absolutely critical roles
to play in protecting America and from
covering law enforcement for 20 years I
know these agencies are made up of very
dedicated hard-working people and they
deserve the tools they need and they
deserve our support the purpose here is
to ask reasonable and constructive
questions that will give ultimately give
us the information we need for informed
decision making and so make our nation
stronger these are questions that come
straight from the smoking craters of the
World Trade Center from the air
conditioned top secret compartment at
halls of the CIA and from the elected
chambers of Congress consider the
following since September 11th the Bush
administration and Congress have
dramatically increased the government's
power to investigate and detain citizens
and non-citizens without the standard
constitutional protections at the same
time the administration has imposed
unprecedented secrecy making it more
difficult for Congress the courts and
citizens
the government accountable this is
despite increasing evidence including
evidence this week from last week from
Congress that the federal intelligence
agencies failed to properly properly
respond to an astonishing number of
indications that the k'da terrorists
were plotting against America in the
years leading up to September 11th this
is also despite past intelligence agency
abuses such as the FBI's campaign in the
1960s to get UC president Clark Kerr
fired as recently disclosed in the San
Francisco Chronicle the USA patriot act
that stands for uniting and
strengthening america by providing
appropriate tools required to intercept
and obstruct terrorism that's a really
nifty acronym for a piece of legislation
that's 342 pages long and amends more
than 15 different laws it was hastily
approved by Congress and signed by
President Bush not October 26 after a
little debate yet it is one of the
biggest expansions of police powers and
decades some examples of the
government's expanded powers under the
Act FBI agents may request business
records which could include library
bookstore and subscription records and
possibly reporters unpublishing
confidential notes when agents believe
the information may be relevant to a
tear of terrorism investigation the
person whose records are sought need not
be a target of the investigation and the
library bookstore a publication that
receives the court order is barred from
even disclosing it the Act modifies the
bank secrecy act to require financial
institutions to more closely track
suspicious transactions and share
reports about them upon request with
government agencies including the CIA
the law also grants federal agent secret
access to personal credit reports the
Act boosts the FBI's power to trace
Internet traffic and collect electronic
address and routing information that
shows what websites law-abiding citizens
are visiting agents need only certify to
a court that the information is quote
relevant to an eye
oying criminal investigation the Act
also makes it easier for the FBI to use
wiretaps bugs and break-ins to gather
intelligence about US citizens by
lowering the standard to get such
warrants from the secret Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court and
finally the act is harshest on
immigrants according to David Cole a
professor at Georgetown University Law
Center the law allows the government to
exclude aliens based solely on political
views deport them based on innocent
political associations and detain them
on the Attorney General say so of course
the Justice Department has also proposed
operation tips which would have used
postal and utility workers to report
suspicious activity inside people's
homes but this plan brought so much
criticism from Congress that the
department has scaled it back although
it still plans to proceed with it
meanwhile there is the increasing
evidence the previous laws laws already
on the books had enabled the FBI and the
CIA together a huge amount of clues
indicating than bin Laden was targeting
the United States now there is no
evidence that the agency's new
specifically about the September 11th
attacks but there is substantial
evidence suggesting that the agency's
failed to properly respond to the clues
showing a nation should have been more
on guard the bush administration has
refused to say exactly what it knew
before the attacks and all this raises
the question of whether the intelligence
agency has truly needed such vastly
expanded powers as provided by the
Patriot Act and other measures at the
same time the administration has
expanded powers and more billions of
dollars to pursue terrorists the
administration is closing down public
scrutiny and reducing the possibility of
accountability Ashcroft has refused to
fully reply to questions from the House
Judiciary Committee about how it is
using the Patriot Act even though the
committee has primary responsibility for
oversight of the Justice Department and
not long after the terrorist attacks
President Bush issued an executive order
that will keep
papers of former presidents that were
supposed to be made public under the
1978 presidential Records Act the
administration claims that the order
will help protect national security but
some historians are concerned that
President Bush is seeking to hide
embarrassing information about
administration officials who previously
worked for his father or for President
Reagan also last year attorney general
Ashcroft issued a memo to all federal
agencies saying that justice justice
department would defend in court all
decisions to deny freedom of information
act requests if there is any sound legal
basis for withholding information this
reverses Attorney General Janet Reno's
policy which required agencies to use
their discretion to release information
whenever there was no foreseeable damage
critics believe the Ashcroft policy will
encourage needless secrecy and
potentially expensive litigation here in
the Bay Area we have seen how a
concentration of secrecy and
intelligence powers can go awry during
times of great international tension
during World War two in the Cold War the
nation granted the FBI expanded powers
to protect against spies and saboteurs
but the FBI misused his power on jun 9th
the chronicle reported that thousands of
pages of FBI documents obtained only
after a 17-year legal fight showed that
in the 1960s the bureau engaged in
wide-ranging and unlawful intelligence
activities at the University of
California the FBI do not want to
release those documents they claimed in
court the disclosure of the records was
not in the public interest that the
information had to remain secret to
protect law enforcement and national
security but five federal judge's order
the FBI to release them concluding the
FBI had engaged in unlawful spying some
of the documents show that the CIA and
the FBI conspired to pressure you seize
Governing Board of Regents to harass
faculty and students involved in dissent
misled the White House the FBI misled
the White House by sending President
Lyndon Johnson allegations that you see
president Clark Kerr had engaged in
disloyal activity even though the FBI
had previously investigated these
allegations and found them false
the FBI mounted a concerted campaign to
get Kerr fired a court found because it
disagreed with his campus policies and
political views even though there was
never any evidence that he was disloyal
in a particularly ironic episode an
optional essay question on you sees
English aptitude test for high school
applicants in 1959 asked what are the
dangers to a democracy of a national
police organization like the FBI which
operates secretly and is unresponsive to
public criticism well what j edgar
hoover heard this question he hit the
roof he ordered he ordered his agents to
mount what is what was essentially a
covert public relations campaign
intended to embarrass the university and
which forced the university to retract
the question and apologize to the FBI
but Hoover wasn't satisfied he ordered
agents to question to check the
backgrounds of all 6,000 professors and
staff members of you see around the
state the result was a 60 paid report
among its findings 72 faculty members
and students were listed in the bureau's
secret security index a list of people
whom the FBI considered potentially
dangerous to national security during a
crisis and who would be detained
indefinitely without judicial warrant
the report also found that 141
professors had committed miscellaneous
misdeeds such as writing a play that
glorified the chinese communist army 54
professors were their family members
subscribed or contributed to
publications that the FBI team
subversive and 22 professors had been
involved in quote illicit love affairs
homosexuality sexual perversion
excessive drinking or other instances of
conducts reflecting mental instability
after the Chronicle story appeared
senator Feinstein asked the FBI to
respond she wanted to know does the FBI
still keep a list of citizens to be
detained in the event of a national
emergency the FBI has yet to respond and
that leaves us wondering whether 17
years from now we'll be waiting to find
out what the government is up to today
Thank You Seth our final panelist is
Paul Weaver my assignment tonight is to
say something about the media and
instead of talking about the media is
institutions and relating them to
foreign policy the way other people
already have done to an extent I thought
instead I would talk a little bit about
lewis lapham and the media and that in
itself is already a big subject Lewis
has kind of hinted at the fact that he
was editor of Harper's at a young age in
the 70s and then he lost Harper's and he
got it back again in a dramatic turn
about of affairs Lewis as an as a
journalist of course you read him all
the time in Harper's every month and now
he has his latest book mostly a
collection of Harper's columns and
essays which I recommend to you and
which I would like to give you a kind of
readers guide to and in the course of
that say a few words about lewis lapham
and journalism and lewis lapham the
journalist journalism I will define
borrowing from one of the James brothers
I can never forget I can never remember
which one but journalism is criticism of
the moment at the moment it's a very
good definition it covers a very broad
range of activity there are lots of
different kinds of journalists and lots
of different divisions within the world
of journalism and one of the most basic
of these is the division between editors
and reporters and the equivalent in
television and radio
lewis clearly is an editor and if you
want to understand his book and
understand and appreciate his writing
and his his lecture of this evening it
helps I think to realize that Lewis is
an editor now an editor is defined by
the fact that he has two main roles or
functions in this world one is to have
lunch and the other is to define reality
now you may think that that at once to
light and too heavy for any one person
to do let alone an editor but actually
every editor does both of those things
and above all does those two things they
really do do a lot of their useful work
going to lunch chatting with authors and
learning from them but also sharing with
them their view of the world and that
gets us to the second role of an editor
which is defining reality modern
scholarship of the media often defines
the editor as a gatekeeper and his
function is that of gatekeeping sort of
letting fish you know up up the fish
ladder or not up the fish ladder but
that's a very poor and limited
definition of what an editor does and
editor controls the editor controls
everything in his publication what it
looks like how long it is who's in it
what subject to watch subjects are
covered what subjects are not covered
who will be allowed in whose name will
be allowed to be mentioned every nuance
of every sentence is considered and
validated by the editor and if he
doesn't like it he changes it editors
are totally in control in the world of
journalism and Louis is very much I
think you can see that in his writing so
as a as a as a writer then what is Louis
like well I would say he's very much
like an editor in his writing by this I
mean two or three different things first
there's an amazing variety of disparate
materials in a typical lapham sentence
or paragraph and certainly in a typical
lapham page there will be memories of
his childhood in San Francisco growing
up looking out over the San Francisco
Bay in seeing the Navy ships at anchor
during World War two and three lines
away from that there will be a brief
summary of what through siddity said
and not far from that there will be some
report of a news story according to the
Associated Press published three years
ago on an obscure subject having to do
with East Asia or American foreign
policy and then there will be flashbacks
to Fifth Avenue parties that he has been
to and then back again to Thucydides or
Aristotle this somewhat unusual and
exotic souffle is actually very typical
of editors they learn through a variety
of different ways and they sort of have
all these different sources of learning
at their fingertips at all times and
they're very personal it's a very solid
cystic world in some sense what unifies
it is only the fact that it's all passed
through and into his mind now another
related aspect of an editor when he
writes is to be found in the fact that
he doesn't labor very heavily at any one
point editor's writing sort of flits
gracefully from one point to another
point from one bit of evidence to
another memory and back again it all
often hangs together if he's a good
editor and writer or if he has a good
editor
but you wouldn't want to accuse this
person of burning the midnight oil he
his writing doesn't reek of learning
tomes gone through four hours for weeks
for months for years on end quite the
contrary there's a kind of a souffle
like quality to the writing and a third
point and this is very interesting in
Lewis's writing there's a certain ohter
a certain almost the air of an
unfriendly way to put it would be
sometimes pompous sometimes
condescending sometimes comic but always
to tulare and a little formal there's an
air of that and much of his writing now
to some extent lewis clearly aspires to
write in a somewhat comic vein and I
actually think that there's a close
parallel between him and Mark Twain but
I won't get into that and at other times
he's more scholarly and I hear echoes of
henry adams in Lois's writing and even
poor Melville but above all I would
simply say he writes like an editor an
editor knows the world is in need of his
guidance and tutelage and you can tell
that and Lewis is deftly amusing
interesting informative but tutelary
writing now what what is Louis's view of
the world well you might guess or some
people might guess given his views
expressed on foreign policy for example
that he has left wing affinities in its
politics others especially others who
read him 20 or 30 years ago imagined
that he was a conservative but actually
he's neither of those that never has
been Lewis is a constitutionalist that's
to say he looks at the world sort of the
way the founding fathers looked at their
world and what makes him weird of course
is that the world has really changed a
lot since the founding fathers were
around but never the never mind that
doesn't mean that what Lewis the way
Lewis looks at this at our world isn't
right in fact I think it is right
without the laboring it too much I would
connect Lewis's sort of founding fathers
classical almost ancient view of our
modern world I would connect that with
the fact that he is a journalist in the
in the book and this is one of the best
passages in the book he tells the story
of how he came back from the grand tour
of Europe in 1957 or whatever and
realized he had to get a job and so he
interviewed at three places one was the
White House when was the Washington Post
and one was the CIA and he got an
interview at the CIA and he for this
interview he had prepared he'd read his
lucida tease and boned up on the English
monarchy succession and gone prepared
that you know discuss high and
historical matters of weighty importance
for the new world power and instead he
was asked three questions the most
important of which was does Muffy
Hamilton wear a slip wafi Hamilton being
apparently a girl much dated by Yale
ease in the mid-50s so Lewis was
horrified by this and instead he became
a journalist
by which I mean really he committed
himself to a line of work in which you
are committing yourself to looking at
the world from the viewpoint of the
ordinary citizen or the more or less
ordinary citizen a journalist doesn't
have any special expertise doesn't have
any special authority he looks at the
world with the authority of the ordinary
the amateur citizen and he looks at the
world therefore from the perspective of
ordinary everyday life which is a
perspective that has both moral and
practical concerns blended in a complex
way and that's why I think his voice is
so valuable and that's why I hope you
will all read him again soon and with
that I'm stop
thank you very much Paul we have many
questions and so I will begin and I'll
address the questions to the individual
participants as we proceed i'll start
with luis the first question is if you
were president what would you do I'm
just glad I'm not president I'm the
amateur citizen as Paul we were just
said and I have no idea what I would do
if I was president I would be seeing the
situation from a completely different
perspective and presumably with a lot
better information second second
question also for Louis is what was your
opinion of El gore speech you mean the
recent speech yes I didn't I didn't hear
Al Gore's reasons page the so I don't
have an opinion Al Gore gave a speech
yesterday in san francisco at the
commonwealth club that that was
basically calling it a question many of
the issues that the panel was raising
and well well i'm in a disadvantage
because i didn't hear it and I didn't
read it this morning so I don't know
what to say a question for the entire
panel is what do we what should we make
of Homeland Security the West start with
Ellen
I think it's just it has such a
mousseline Ian sound to it doesn't it um
you know we're on guard in the homeland
and and we will make it secure from evil
thoughts witches and wizards and other
things that go bump in the night you
know if the things that are bumping in
the night dar you know phantoms across
the world then we'll have to you know
sort of mold and exaggerated our
perception of them you know they failed
on 911 these guys are the ones that were
supposed to be protecting us and instead
of any heads rolling they all got
promoted and reshuffled around on the
deck of the Titanic that's absurd
Homeland Security means for me mostly a
new form of color coding of our daily
security and I'm at a disadvantage
because I'm colorblind so I can't tell
well I guess Homeland Security gets back
to how you define security and who's
secure it is and that should be open to
debate I guess I have two thoughts first
it when you look at its origin and the
way it began it was pretty clearly an
exercise in media politics the White
House needed to do something to get put
out an image of doing something fast and
dramatic and this looks fast it was fast
and it looks dramatic so on the one hand
I want to say it looks like a pretty
much empty gesture on the other hand
let's not underestimate what happens in
Washington they make all these dramatic
and somewhat empty
gestures but real money and real power
are eventually assembled in their names
and then someone gets his hands on the
power and the money and turns it the
some objective often not the one
originally intended so I don't think we
really know what Homeland Security and
practice is going to mean but it could
mean something significant we don't know
what it is it might not be good our next
question is also for the panel and the
question is how can we deter well let's
see i mentioned rethinking american
foreign policy you know i would have and
i wrote it at the time we never should
have sent the troops into saudi arabia
in the first place and we should have
taken them out not because of sama bin
Laden was was kvetching about them but
but because they didn't serve American
interests and we need to reassess
American industries and what they really
are and whether some of the things that
we've been doing for years and years and
decades all those bases in Germany South
Korea and and Okinawa I mean are they
are they helping us to deter terrorism
or they are they stirring it up the
questions need to be asked and you know
get spread out you know they like these
centralized things so the more we
decentralize America the better we are
I think first of all we recognize that
terrorism is a crime it's not something
you wage war against you age concerted
organized and cooperative police action
against it which means you try to
maintain international cooperation
rather than shifting the whole subject
towards regime change and getting the
rest of the world mad at you secondly
you do as many of us pointed out you do
we think policies that are
counterproductive and that they don't
achieve any of your core values but do
anger millions of people around the
world and thus lend aid and comfort to
terrorists whatever their particular
motives may be and I've you know as I
don't finally deter terrorists
necessarily you do fight them but you
fight them wisely and not by I might
just make one other point which is if
you notice where the huge increases in
the military budget are coming many of
them are coming in things like new
stealth bombers and weapons for fighting
a new Cold War that has nothing at all
to do with the alleged threat out there
and so finally you don't waste precious
national resources on threats that are
irrelevant to the problem at hand well
certainly through a fair and equitable
foreign policy that that doesn't seek to
topple other people's governments and
lead to blow back and perhaps a certain
amount of terrorism is unavoidable and
in those cases we can protect against it
through well-trained well-funded and
accountable law enforcement agencies I
really comes as no surprise that the FBI
and the CIA don't have informants in the
Middle East they don't have an adequate
number of translators if you've been
covering federal courts over the years
you know that the FBI doesn't even have
enough translators to transcribe tapes
in
in mob cases or organized crime cases
involving crime groups of different
countries so that's something that could
have been fixed a long time ago I don't
know about terrorists but our terrorism
but we certainly were attacked by a
group of specific terrorists and that
problem we should be doing something
about we should be responding you can't
stand by and be attacked just as the
police department can't stand by when
people are murdering folks on the street
so that's that's the part of the
response that I think is important and
I'd like to see it done more
aggressively and without em with better
focus question for a question for Lewis
why do you think there's more opposition
in the British Parliament and public
than here I think there's more a
tradition of political argument in
dissent in England and I did Tocqueville
when he comes to the United States in
the 1830s is surprised at how reluctant
the Americans were to engage in free
expression I mean they had it in their
constitution but in practice they were
often afraid of going against what he
referred to as a tyranny of the majority
and I find the same thing here and when
you look at the question period on
c-span in the parliament you see the
rather fierce exchange of ID and opinion
between the members of parliament and
you don't usually see that in our
Congress and you don't really see it in
our press either and I would attribute
it to our sometimes too sensitive not
wanting to hurt each other's
feelings and in the in the September
11th when they were doing the
remembrance day in New York that was the
theme of the whole day everybody must be
made to feel comfortable and we tend to
do that we I once had a television show
and we'd have guests I have guests and
panelists who would say that they would
come on and want to argue with each
other on some point and in the green
room they'd be very fierce and what they
were going to say and then when they got
out in front of the camera they all
became very light and and circumspect I
just think it may be a national trait a
sort of a follow-up question in
reference to the quote that you had from
Krauthammer a questioner is asking how
close do you think we are to the Lord
Acton quote power corrupts and absolute
power corrupts absolutely well I think
actins right and I think power does
corrupt and it we get the these naive
notions of Krauthammer that the sense
that we can do as we will with the world
I mean you read some of the policy
institute papers by that back up the
neoconservative foreign policy positions
and people talk very blithely about I
read one a couple of months ago whether
people were sitting around a conference
table in Washington and thinking that
maybe they would drop an atomic bomb on
Afghanistan not for any specific
military objective but just to
demonstrate to Syria Lebanon and Egypt
in other countries in the Middle East
what sort of thing could be done I mean
it was a very fantastic discussion and
that to me is a form of corruption when
you get divorced from reality and think
that you can do as you will without some
form of international cooperation or
some understanding of other people is he
another question for the panel is what's
the relationship of oil to position
I'm not going to say much I think
there's some relationship what strikes
me is is that we talk about cheap Middle
Eastern oil and we never count the cost
of all the military forces that are
deployed in the Middle East and the
Persian Gulf and and if you and I and a
years ago I did a column that that that
that tried to estimate all those costs
and what a gallon of water barrel of oil
would cost in those terms and I can't
remember the numbers but it's a
fantastic number if you take all the
costs into account so it can't possibly
be for cheap oil because the oil is not
cheap and it's about to get a whole lot
more expensive so i must say that i'm
kind of mystified i think its power game
in rich oil is a tool but i'm not sure
all's the big thing well in in 1991 you
may remember President Bush Senior at
one point was asked about why we needed
to go to ward he said basically it was
to protect our vital oil supplies very
quickly he changed tune and said we were
just intervening against Iraq to
preserve democracy in that part of the
world and from that point on right so
much of it from that point on we stopped
talking about anything as concrete or as
messy as oil but sure oil is is a big
factor it has been from day one in our
policy in the Middle East going back to
the 1940s I mentioned the coup that we
sponsored in 1953 in Iran following the
government's nationalization of the
foreign oil consortium the following
year the State Department oversaw the
reorganization of a new private foreign
oil consortium in which the United
States had a very large interest the
1963 coup in Iraq followed that
government's partial nationalization of
foreign oil consortium
it's been a huge interest of the United
States it's been a huge interest in
recent years as the United States has
played a huge chess game trying to
dictate the laying of oil pipelines from
the Caspian Sea and from various
countries in the former Soviet Union all
over South Asia there was a period of
several years when United States
supported the Taliban regime because it
was considering an oil pipeline that
would go through Afghanistan to be built
by unocal and the current member of the
National Security Council who's the
expert on Afghanistan was yoona kells
Afghan representative and lobbyist on
that pipeline project so yes oil is a
very important factor the reasons are
complex both for economic reasons even
if the oil even if the cost of acquiring
the oil exceeds the value of the oil is
Alan put it there are particular
interest groups who benefit from access
to that oil who have a disproportionate
impact on our foreign policy so they've
socialized the cost of getting that oil
and they privatize the benefits
well to the extent that oil is a factor
in our foreign policy and perhaps a
negative factor it it get it does raise
a question that has not discussed very
much anymore which which is what is the
country doing to make itself less
dependent on oil and I would add only
the thought that mostly what we're
talking about is cheap oil remember in
America a gallon of gasoline costs well
into two dollars everywhere else in the
world it costs to three times that much
and what a lot of our diplomacy is aimed
not at supplying or gara at stabilizing
supplies of necessary oil but at making
sure that we can drive enormous SUVs for
a tiny fraction of what we probably
really ought to be paying to run them
that's the part of this that troubles me
more than that were defending national
interests in oil that it seems to me is
an appropriate name of policy but
defending really cheap gas that's dumb
a question for Louis is is President
Bush using military focus of the United
States to carry out a family vendetta
against Iraq I don't know the answer to
that question ID I can't read into the
head of Bush I'm told by people that
know him that there is a vengeful streak
in it that he genuinely feels that
Hussein is a villain who must be
destroyed and apparently they're there
is a angry hatred of Hussein but where
that comes from I don't know I don't
know whether his father gave it to him
or well I don't know how he comes by
that I don't trust the kind of
journalism or history that reads into
other people's heads I do think that
both I think Bush is a true believer I
mean like Ashcroft and there they are
both equipped with a messianic spirit
which i think is dangerous no matter
where it shows up whether it shows up on
the side of the Arab jihadist or an
American evangelist I'm always wary of
the Messianic
I think Cheney and Rumsfeld are cynics
cynical and and who well what's I don't
know I'd the all foot seems to me to be
a zealot of some form with with some I
won't say crazed idea but the some
visionary notion and I that I think is
probably very unrealistic I'm not sure
what the basis of the unreality is a
question for Jonathan Marshall is isn't
massive retaliation against when one's
enemies the only course to take I guess
it depends on what the enemy is done and
who the enemy is if there's an enemy
that's identifiable and threatening your
life or the life of your country
potentially so but first of all I think
it's incumbent upon us and certainly
part of all the rules of war that we
claim to subscribe to that we not
massively retaliate against the entire
civilian population of a country so that
we try to narrowly target our force and
use force only when truly necessary I
think the grave danger of the new Bush
foreign policy is its messianic thrust
and instead of you know as a great many
conservative realest people like Brent
Scowcroft even Henry Kissinger who are
not exactly liberals have warned against
this notion of preventive strikes
against real and imagined potential
future dangers as they pointed out if
every country started practicing this
kind of foreign policy it would be
deadly Anarchy it would be kind of real
wide bloodbath this is a radical foreign
policy that's being engaged in not a
conservative foreign policy
and I think therefore you know what
we've done we're going out in search of
enemies rather than really trying to
protect true national security a
follow-up question that's related for
jonathan is what actually is the story
about nuclear weapons in Iraq I'm really
not an expert on that I gather that both
the report that Tony Blair released
today in Parliament from his own
intelligence sources and the recent
report by the International Institute
for Strategic Studies both concluded
that this is not a prime threat the big
problem for Iraq is getting fissile
material ie uranium or plutonium that's
processed and because they don't have a
reactor and apparently had been unable
to acquire this in the least large
enough quantities most experts that I've
read and know about don't think that
this is an imminent threat it doesn't
mean that if he didn't get it he
probably could put a bomb together
fairly fast he probably wouldn't be able
to deliver it by a missile any place of
consequence but of course today the
problem despite our billions of dollars
spent on missile defense the real
problem is of course you could bring a
weapon in just in a freighter and blow
it up in New York Harbor but sure I
wouldn't deny that there is a long run
threat that was saying left to his own
devices could get access to weaponry but
I would point out that the country that
most recently acquired weapons of mass
destruction ie nuclear weapons was
Pakistan which is now our great ally and
personally I'm much more concerned that
some terrorists will bump off Musharraf
and some intelligence zealots who are
fundamentalist will take over the
country and we
we'll have a bunch of crazies and
control of nuclear weapons I think we
all ought to be much more concerned
about that then what Saddam Hussein is
up to right now another question for
Louis what is your view of the imperial
presidency and presidential war powers
well I would be opposed to the imperial
presidency and I the and I would like to
see the war powers granted in the way
they were supposed to be granted by the
Constitution which is to say by the
Congress very straightforward answer
another question for Louis is why do you
think Tony Blair is so slavishly your
slavish being a supporter of Bush's war
policy well I don't know he is also a
twice-born and an evangelical in the
same way that Bush is so there is this
christian notion of crusade somewhere in
players thinking but but otherwise I I
don't know i have a sort of a quick
comment is someone who considers himself
a Christian it's really hard for me to
find a whole lot of endorsement of
preventive war pre-emptive war and even
a whole lot of war at all in anything
that Jesus said it's certainly been used
over the centuries in in
in ways that have had a lot more to do
with the immediate power advantages of
those who were calling themselves
Christians at the time and the church
has certainly been a very human
institution in that it has plenty of
flaws and faults and tends to breed
sometimes at various times in history
people with sort of megalomaniacal
notions but I don't find in the Gospels
a whole lot that would give much aid and
comfort to Wolfowitz or Ashcroft or Tony
Blair there's only readers of the Old
Testament a another question for Lewis
is considering lack of dissent over many
of these measures which are obviously
dramatic changes and the lack of debate
generally speaking over these dramatic
changes what is your view of your being
attacked by the Americans for violence
our victory over terrorism
I didn't know that I'd been attacked by
such a group that's it he is the group
that built in it and others oh well I
would take that as a normal course of
events I mean that the if that is the
Bennett Cheney alumni trustees Council
crowd in Washington they are very rabid
supporters of the war on terrorism and
they came out with a report shortly
during the fall of last year and in
which they were they quoted a hundred
and fifty you know student university
students professors around the country
and accuse them of being disloyal for
saying very bland things such as I can't
remember they were so bland I mean to
people with people say war is not good
and and that was enough to prompt an
attack from Bennett on the ground of
that was somehow a disloyal remark I
mean it was the observations were of
that character a last question are you
something so the audience knows Lewis
was referred to by Bennett and Americans
for victory over terrorism as an
internal enemy so that we now have a
Nixon style enemies list and Lewis will
be able to wear this is a badge of honor
well
last question these questions by the way
many people are asking similar questions
and here's another good example um is
what can the average American do to
learn more about what's going on and do
to affect these policies and stretch of
Lewis well you read and write I mean as
Paul Weaver would say there there are
lots of ways of getting better
information I mean there are magazines
there are websites that there is the
Foreign Press the news I mean it the
news is not something that is
necessarily given to you I mean it's
something you have to make and
participate in and form your own idea
democracy is the hardest possible form
of government because it records
requires a high degree of literacy and
it requires paying attention so it's not
only informing yourself but then trying
to take the possibly political action
maybe you run for office maybe you stage
a complaint or maybe you start a
magazine or they're all kinds of ways of
trying to express one's opinion in
objection one of them is this kind of a
crowd in this kind of a room tonight
I want to apologize for not being able
to get to all of your questions there
are just many many excellent questions
but I think this evening we've started
hopefully a discussion and more on
behalf of the independent Institute
harper's magazine in the world affairs
council Northern California I want to
thank all of our speakers especially
lewis lapham and our panel for their
excellent presentation
lewis lapham is the editor of Harper's
Magazine and author of theater of war
it's published by the New